All right, so first introduction, my name is Dr. Kevin Colors. I've been practicing since
oh boy, 1986. Starting out as a chiropractor, practicing still water Minnesota with my first
down the Woodbury, that's still water. And did I practice kinesiology and nutrition since then?
Left to do some missionary work for a period of time, came back and started seeing more live and
cancer patients. If you anybody has been on our website, yes,
seriously, a couple people. So I'd suggest you do so because you can download our books. This is
our most popular book, stopped by the cancer and started reading the cause. Our live book is a
free download on our website too. On that little flyer that you got here, that's what the live
book looks like. You'll see it in a million times. There are slides today. So that's you go on the
website, you can click on it, download it as a free PDF download. Also my book is called Your Crazy
and then the subtitle is in other things, what is the subtitle? It's a very good way to come to it.
And other crazy things doctors tell people who need brain therapy. So that's our whole book on
understanding the brain, understanding what inflammation does to the brain. So if you have live, you
probably have some brain-based issues that book would also greatly help you. There's also another
book I didn't bring up in a copies event because we're out of them right now. It's called Help Your
Body's Killing Me. That's a book on autoimmune diseases. That's what we're really going to hit
tonight when we talk about live disease. And that will be also very helpful. That's a shorter
read book. So I suggest you download those. They're all free. You can also order a little Amazon if you
like a hard copy and we have some copies here. So we hope to have some time for questions afterwards.
We have a lot to go over. So who here has live disease? Okay, who here has a friend that has
live disease? Who here wants to have live disease? One hand at the back there. So
chronic live disease is something that is near to my heart because I had live twice.
Never went into the chronic phase. My daughter has chronic line that didn't go into the chronic
phase. The doctor that works as read as Dr. Kelly Holler, but maybe some of you may know her because
she lived up here for a period of time. She had chronic line that went to the chronic phase to the
autoimmune phase, which we're going to talk about. And I'm going to give you a distinction there.
There's a difference there in my book about that. And she was on her deathbed
matter fact she had last rights given to her. So she was very sick. Now she works full-time with me.
So there is like Jane said stories of great hope. We've had patients come into our office in
wheelchairs and art in wheelchairs anymore. But it is a process. I'm going to say something that
is not going to be real probably well received to a chronic line patient, but it is true.
Chronic line patients are more difficult to take care of than our stage 4 cancer patients.
That's just the way it is because stage 4 cancer patient is either they get better kind of on a
linear scale. So they're either going to get better or they're not going to get better. There's kind
of going between. A chronic line patient gets better like this. Okay? You're a chronic line
you know what it's like. Some days they come doing much better. I got this beat and then the next day
you're kicking on a band. So it's very discouraging. That's part of the debilitating part of
chronic line is that the discouragements could just be overwhelming. A little bit more about my
background. I went back to school a number of years ago and I got a degree in functional medicine
and AMA degree in integrative cancer therapy. I don't do any chiropractic anymore. That's all
we deal with now is cancer patients and chronic line patients. The Dr. Hallerman is a functional
neurologist MD that she deals a lot with the brain-based aspect. We do neurofeedback in our office
in a lot of home brain-based therapy issues. About 75% of our patients come from out of state or
on the country. If clients spend a week with us and we get them started on a program.